hey you my name is Thomas TomSka
ridgewell and I am the best Tom and uh
this is my channel and I set this up so
I'm the best Tom that is your opinion
and it's wrong
can you tell we're trying to do the
intro for this like five different times
and then we just used your default one I
mean it's it's just it's it's very
natural I love talking about myself
because I'm the best Tom I I hate
talking about myself and I'm also
apparently not self-comfort enough to
even like jokingly say I'm the best you
don't need to talk about yourself
because you have ideas but when you run
out of ideas it's really easy to fall
back on yourself
I'm like dry as a bone creatively so I
just like it's me time we're gonna play
board games and uh the winner is the
best Tom that's that's it that's the
video let's figure it out yeah game one
right so
we should probably Shuffle these we
should yeah that would be a very short
game oh it's a fresh pack as well yep
not anymore
all right I'm trying not to get them
sweaty
I think if we match on suit or number
Jesus
take him off to our side whoever's got
more at the end of the day gets the
point beautiful all right all right you
want to go for a second there we go done
I'm gonna have to bleep this oh yeah
okay we yeah I cannot swear it just
comes so naturally all right I'm I'm
already losing
flap
I did it I feel like you let me I feel
like you let me didn't I wasn't that's
that's four hearts in a row it is I did
try to shuffle it all right
[Music]
yes didn't even didn't even move oh
exciting on the suit I mean it's like on
one hand it doesn't matter because it's
a YouTube video on the other hand it is
my entire like validity as a human uh
that's at stake right now
[Music]
I think I got cocky because I won that
last one I think I got desperate because
I didn't
yeah
I think okay
that went really hard uh yeah
[Music]
oh God
It's gotta be it's gonna be so tight
right now no you're you're ahead I'm I'm
doomed this is it's on you I've got to
win this on you
I'm gonna win this I gotta win this I
gotta win this I gotta win this this is
the most yeah okay I'm only looking I
can still do it you fool you arrogant
fool
[Music]
nope okay
well
no God I think I think it's still yeah
foreign
[Music]
25 son of a gun 26.
four in it damn that's four cards were
in it
that's fine that's game one okay
okay I was like we have to play this
nine more times no that's that's that's
one point son of
game two
see now I'm overconfident now I'm
challenging I know now I'm threatened so
oh okay I can be psyched out all right
let's so about like two years ago middle
lockdown I remember looking up an
article that was like the best strategy
for Connect Four it's a solved game and
I looked at that and I went that's too
complicated it's the middle of lockdown
I can't be bothered to learn this right
now if you
Instagram
yeah I didn't yeah if you just like if
you've just done game theory on that I'd
just give up it's a solved game like if
you play against a computer it can win
or draw every time oh
um but I do not know what that strategy
is good so I'm just gonna be winging it
right uh Connect Four I feel like the
rules are they haven't changed yep you
connect four I don't know who's meant to
go first yeah
um but you are behind so YouTubes oh
thanks first a second no please go ahead
all right show me how it's done
I want to go here
you're gonna like You're Gonna Go full
enemy like rookie mistake
um no Tom please
sure
[Music]
I mean it was well yeah it wouldn't have
been amazing if I just let you yes
that's it over
[Music]
why did I even put it there there was no
hope there was no I did yeah sure I'm
smart
come on sorry oh not actually sorry I've
killed myself I think I've killed myself
not entirely I mean but also there's so
many Avenues you now have
to just ruin my day
[Music]
you can you can oh God oh God
this is gonna be a short one
[Music]
there's nothing I can do I'm not sure
it's it's either a draw it's not like
this you can it depends it depends if I
put something either it's just
immediately over yeah but you might be
able to force me to play those I would I
hope so I'm trying to set up something
else yeah
oh this sucks sorry this is rubbish
I don't yeah that's there now I just all
I can go do is go up
no stop stop it
[Music]
come on give me something thank you
there I'm on the oh wait no I think
I
think
that just lost you and I think it was
that move that did it because
I've now got two I can win on instead of
one
I'm not sure if it was inevitable or not
I feel like it probably was
no hang on
I'm wrong I'm wrong
because now you have to do one of those
which means I get to at least block one
end of that but then you can yeah but
now I yeah yeah
but ah damn okay someone's gonna do an
in-depth game analysis of that and I
don't wear it oh it's over I just I want
to keep going uh so
come on came free
oh okay this I'm worried I'm gonna break
this I feel like yeah do we go for one
hippo each or oh or do we do two hippos
each I think I think now you've said it
yeah two hippo time launch all the
marbles by pressing the black buttons
whoever's birthday is next gets to yell
go
two months ago it's mine uh now gobble
the marbles as fast as you can whoever
Chomps the most marbles wins
okay all right all right launch the
marbles
okay that was very quick we have one
more marble we have one more marble okay
I have nine don't stop now nine are you
kidding me it's still down to this it's
down to this marble
it's down to this marble top come on
this is for all the [ __ ] quite literally
uh I kind of I just want to make sure
it's like nicely yeah balanced okay may
the best Marvel win
go
yes I win one finally
I was so tempted to flip this board I
was like I was like do I no I don't
yes I do
I mean it's your place you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to go at the
marbles to find they're all good it's
fine
wow
how do you play buggle just so you know
Tom uh the crew picked these games
without like Consulting uh I'm good at
this one so they don't know that you are
Boggle world champion I'm 2003. if I
lose this I will be very angry at myself
cool and good
it's always not very angry at me but you
won't because I don't know what this
game is
ah okay so uh how this works is
and then you have to make as many words
as possible
by connected or diagonal paths uh so so
you could have that's a I am out of
practice at this uh it's not a valid
word it's a name but you could have
Chris
okay uh if the if that was slightly
different
you could have
well we don't look at we don't always
get what we want okay I nearly said
crispy and that wasn't even a deliberate
mess up that was no
you know I was really confident at the
start yeah yeah yeah you get more points
for longer words and we'll figure that
out later if I can get like a seven
letter it's worth loading do we only get
to submit one word or is it just as many
words as many words as you want but if
we both write the same word down it
cancels out just to make the scrolling
easier we need like DM screens or
something here but honestly I don't
think we're gonna oh we really do uh oh
foreign
I'll do the timer all right three two
one
all right three letters is your minimum
is MEEP a word
um
[Music]
laughs
that was the worst shut up okay do we
even have to go through this next one
we're good it's locks the word I really
hope it is yes but like I put in here
oh thank you I didn't get Peter either
yes I didn't get rad
did it get red that's red oh yeah yeah
red yeah I get red I got red it's right
there I got red I got red and I got hex
oh yeah cross them out let's count up
shall we let's see now oh yeah
I'm the only person with a piece of
paper I have one by default
this is despite Factory so many people
bought the metal posters last time they
sponsored this Channel that I thought
I'd actually come over and show folks
how they're manufactured when you place
an order for a display it's custom made
here they print designs from video games
Comics NASA directly onto metal or
they're a beautiful original pieces from
talented artists after printing they'll
have the gloss on that coating
optionally frame it up then bundle it up
with a fancy magnet mounting system so
you don't need any tools to put it up in
your home and you can also get their 3D
magnets so the posters seem to hover
away from the wall it's all packaged up
for delivery and sent out to one of
their two and a half million customers
so if you want something like that on
your wall or you're looking for a
Christmas present this plates Black
Friday deal is on with up to 42 off
until the end of the month right back to
the show
all right oh boy
this will be interesting this is gonna
be interesting all right Jenga okay
which comes in some kind of fancy oh
there's a thing now that's uh wow edge
of your seat fun the bourgeoisie has got
to Jenga you're on your first second I
don't yeah I can it doesn't really make
a difference I think all right the real
drama kicks off you were gonna you are a
sick man I mean I'm tempted to yeah okay
yeah I was tempted to start with the
sidewalk yeah that would have been very
very funny
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
place
that's resting on it
[Music]
fine you're fine
don't believe in yourself
we are just going to take out all the
all the easy middle blocks there isn't a
block below here that's there isn't a
row below here that's got three three
left
every Row from here down yep is
untouchable now yeah
don't but you have committed is that how
that works have you committed to the
piece I think you can change no it's
it's fine rules said you could show you
actually actually looked at the rules of
Jenga
and gas rules
[Music]
let it stabilize oh this was a mistake I
can't push it back in you can do it go
on do it no don't do it go on
thinking maybe towards you rather than
just stay back I want no part in
whatever's Happening Here
no no how could you do this to a poor
little building
six let's go
nice oh okay
yeah is there I feel like there's
probably there's a logical strategy that
is unfortunate I think I do know it I
hate the way you are yeah
um every day you choose to be this way
you could stop at any time
the thing is I know some strategy for
this I don't know like ship placement
yeah
uh we have to announce when our ship is
sunk right yeah yeah okay do we yeah
probably okay okay who who goes first in
this one you want to flip for it sure
heads
it's tail okay your shot first sure uh
I'm gonna go with
I won Miss oh come on
that's a Miss okay miss miss miss damn
it uh Miss though Miss beaten
it's a hit sorry Tom no
pumpkin
d8
is a hit yes you have you have hit a
ship B1 uh hit yeah sure are we at D7
hit yeah I thought I thought so
what do I look horizontal you do B3
which is a very horizontal kind of guy
yeah weirdly enough that yeah and you
have sunk my little guy okay
hit and you still have not sunk anything
oh I'm getting a big boy
D5 uh it's a hit and you sunk my
battleship shocker
foreign
like the name of the game yes
it's a miss
that's a mess I'm gonna go with E1 is a
hit
yes uh but that is a mess Miss let's try
F1 hit we
he's going down
he's yelling timber E2 uh E2 is that's a
hip I mean I've completely messed up my
search pattern here I've just realized
but I'll take it big day for you
okay well then uh G1 there's a hit yeah
it is uh and then finally H1 is a hit
and you sunk a ship
[Music]
oh I've got the wrong strategy here
let's go with uh G7 it's a miss
F2
is a hit have I sunken you haven't h8 is
a hit yeah I have just realized how
badly I've messed this up have you know
yep because I think you're fine did we
have like a confession camping this
would be the bit where I would walk off
and explain exactly how and for what
reason I know I've just lost I don't
know if you have I
uh whose child is it yours
a G2 shockingly you've hit but not
something he's still going let's go with
uh H6 H6 is a hit to shockingly it's not
a sink oh I'm getting your
boys wait what
I'm that
here's how I know I've just lost oh
you've got my big boys wait oh so I have
more small ones than you
wait
wait did I I did the H5 right you have
not yet done the H5 oh you've grouped
them okay fine I'm gonna go with the G8
is a hit and you have sunk my two length
[ __ ] oh no I don't know what it's
actually called okay I'm just calling it
the two length one I'm sure they've got
names in the fancy book oh you really
did group them okay
um I've only got one ship left now so I
will sink on well hopefully I2 syncs a
[Music]
I mean the good thing for me is you've
got to hit a ship somewhere there's only
one left I've got three targets here I10
it would have been really funny if you
just yeah it would have been great
you've missed damn it that would have
been wonderful though that would have
been great oh
uh F6 oh it's a hit okay B4
is a hit
that's the game that's got to be the
game finish it I hate are you daddy you
sunk a little boy that's a good four
didn't it there was a stowaway on that
ship a little boy is dead Z4 oh it's a
Miss oh damn oh no I've got two turns
maybe three left if I'm lucky you can do
this h
four page four is you're not gonna
believe this is a miss
uh let's go with B3 there's a hit oh no
that's a shame for him ah H sit now H7
H7 is it's not it's just not the vibe uh
and you know what let's go with Chalet
or should I just start going somewhere
else let's go with B5 that is the game
wow oh
yeah
three games remaining oh boy and it's
three hole Yeah so none of that made any
difference no it was all pointless I
mean nothing James Evans
great great which rules are we going
with oh I don't know all right let's
let's look at the actual rules of Uno
and now a graphic about the actual rules
of Uno
uh are we we're house ruling this then
yeah we can stack we can start is the
thing so the the only change like if I
if I play a plus two or plus four you
can bat one back at me yeah all right
yes five blue
plus two I'm on the offensive
immediately stop it well then I will be
on the offensive that was a really bad
decision on my part
I didn't think that through I was just
like I'm gonna come out the gate I
haven't got one to back that up that was
that was a mistake this traditional
probability that I would have a cluster
of my stuff yeah no I realized that the
moment I played it down that I'd made it
made a mistake there um who goes after
two uh I think you do I've drawn I feel
you okay nine nine
six okay
four I don't know I'd love six
yellow
one
three this has gone very badly for me
eight two
[Music]
[Laughter]
this game will go on for half an hour
wow that was the perfect game incredible
I had no other moves I could make I I
went wrong at the start by going oh I'll
just hit him with it oh no that
huh what a rush
I lost that was devastating that was
everything you did set me up for the
next card like and I had no other
choices anyway from that you shifted
colors at just the right time every time
like one that was that was the worst
game of Uno that was the bitterness ever
played in history yeah that was lovely
wow 340u oh God now I feel bad I Gotta
Throw the next one just to keep it
tennis you know oh God that's this is
Match Point yeah I'm feeling cocky now
that could be my undoing I've got to win
this one you do all right you do we got
to keep the stakes High
game eight
movies think I think you might have this
one maybe I mean this is the thing
though is that like wouldn't it be great
if I lost this one so hard
um yeah so we're just gonna do the um
the simple party game version the simple
the really short
name movies until you panic okay
so there's a category you have to name
the movie in that category and hit the
buzzer before it runs out and it just
goes back yeah so it'll be a card is
drawn so for example uh movies where
someone goes to jail and then Redemption
yeah so you'd hit that and then the
timer starts for 15 seconds and I say
something I say the rock because they go
to a jail uh yeah and then I hit it the
time it starts and it keeps going to one
of us goes oh God I know this all right
oh god oh no oh and then it's over how
many are we playing to I guess it's one
it's just I mean we've done one of
everyone else so we can we can do best
of three I mean no you're right we just
got to shuffle the deck and go for one
here I've got to win this you do I've
got to win this and I should win this
because I've seen movies yeah you have
way more I I am not but I think I have I
feel your mind is going to be better at
drawing
trivia memory to the Forefront all right
I think I'm more likely to panic
we have got movies that are more than 40
years old oh my God Gone With the Wind
okay
um Some Like It Hot
The Italian Job I think the original
ones was in the 60s yep
40 years ago was 1982.
um Anything For A Hard Day's Night
oh gross
um okay then uh the Omega Man yeah
oh I know it doesn't seem right
um
train arriving at a station
Birth of a Nation if we're going oh
really look I just I know it's old
that's 1970s um
uh the titfield Thunderbolt
there are just so many movies
32 steps how many steps is it something
like a hot Jesus Christ I already said
it you did it I did
oh
that's for all so so none of that
mattered no it's all down to the final
game and how many times I need to
explain to you that nothing matters
anyway we've just like we've we've we've
we've what's the word we've killed time
uh delayed the inevitable I was gonna
say like held our own end up you know
yeah um
this doesn't count for anything it's not
like we actually prove who's best Tom
and yet I really really care about it it
is important really
game night oh God
it's rock paper scissors oh
no no
brilliant
rock paper scissors do we have to do
best of one here yeah I think so
we have to be best of one of course we
do of course we do oh my God okay now
we've got to psych each other out we're
gonna try and figure out who the okay
what kind of person the other one is
important stuff are we going one two
three throw or are we going one two
throw one two three throw one two three
throw yeah it's not like one two three
anyone who doesn't threes okay this is
unhinged okay
me
okay
sure okay
I'm ready I'll I'll just um do we do are
we all both doing at the same time is
that how that works okay
oh this sucks this sucks so hard it
sucks so hard
um I am more nervous about this like
other things I've done on this channel
because it's it's this is important this
is really important
okay sure okay okay
all right I'll let you count in
one two three throw
so you've threw scissors I did
intentionally I saw you picked that up
and then think that was what I wanted to
do yeah yeah so I threw Rock thinking
you were double bluffing no and wanted
me to throw paper I threw scissors
thinking that it would make you think I
was gonna throw scissors through I threw
paper I think
your game meet Tom needs a Tom yay
that's the best day of my life I mean
this is the best day of my life at a
suitable recording volume
Battle of the toms winner 2020. I was
thinking that so hard about delightful
I'm sorry oh thank you
[Music]